[Music]
[Music]
rated pg-13 how's it going everybody
it's Warren and we have a brand new TV
spot for Avengers in game most likely
the final one before it's released
worldwide tomorrow I know there are many
countries around the world where it has
already been released but for us not so
fortunate ones the movie will come out
tomorrow and in this new TV spot we have
a very tiny bit of new footage but it is
very important new footage it was very
brief in fact if you blinked you
probably missed it it's the scene at the
very end where Thanos is holding up his
sword but the important part about this
scene isn't fan OHS it's the background
as you can see his army is in the
background of this scene in fact this
very much looks like Tony Stark's vision
from age of Ultron were unfamiliar with
what planet they're on but obviously
this is of course the Avengers versus
Thanos and his whole entire army some
people think that thanasis army just
went away after the events of infinity
war or that Thor killed them all well
that wasn't Thanos his whole army his
army is massive he has the outriders and
the Chitauri and as you can see in this
very brief clip he uses them in Avengers
endgame we of course knew this from many
leaks that we've gotten including the
lego leaks that have shown fan OHS
attack with the outriders the Avengers
headquarters however it's very unclear
in this scene where exactly Fanus is we
see his ship in the background the
sanctuary - in the air and we see the
ships carrying the outriders on the
surface of whatever planet they're on so
the Avengers definitely have their hands
full and Avengers endgame be sure to let
me know what you think about this do you
think this could be Tony's vision from
age of Ultron let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and a
reminder about my giveaway I'm giving
away a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and
a glow-in-the-dark famous painting by
globe by boat you can also find more of
his work at globe abode com I'll put the
link in the description down below all
you have to do to enter the giveaway is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain also if you read the comments be
warned people have seen the movie and
are posting spoilers in the comments
section of some videos but still let me
know what you think about this brand new
TV spot as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby
now you're number